commençons par le commencement
la jeunesse de noël une fête chrétienne
l'une des plus importantes qui permet de
revivre symboliquement la naissance de
jésus dans une étable une célébration
religieuse apparu dans le calendrier
chrétien au 6e siècle qui a donc un sens
particulier mais au delà de la religion
noël est devenu au fil des ans plus
universel la symbolique religieuse
réservé aux pratiquants pour les autres
quel que soit le pays quelle que soit la
religion
croyants ou non noël est plutôt
l'occasion de se retrouver de partager
un bon repas d'offrir des cadeaux
aujourd'hui quand on parie de la fête la
plus célébrée au monde
on pense à des heures interminables
d'embouteillage pour accéder aux centres
commerciaux et supermarchés parce qu'il
faut acheter de quoi garnir les tables
et oui noël est synonyme de gourmandise
le fait de partager
on est là on ne les lâche la famille on
dépense beaucoup plus ça ces chiots et
ali kadjo il ya le chocolat il faut
acheter pratiquement tous et en
martinique le repas de noël a une
importance capitale traditionnelle ou
pas à cette date la table est le lieu
par excellence de convivialité autour
d'un plat l'on se réunit pour fêter noël
j'avais fait en reparle famille alors
avec des pois d'angole à désigner
du cochon des liqueurs et un peu d'être
le porte monnaie ne le sait que trop
bien qui dit noël dit cadeau il suffit
d'aller faire un petit tour dans les
magasins pour s'en rendre compte
les files d'attentes sont interminables
les allées sont bondées qu'importe
à noël on veut faire plaisir aux petits
comme aux grands
c'est geste d'amour geste pouvoir
remercier pour tout ce qu on plane et
toujours des cas douanes toujours c'est
pour moi c est conditionnel n'aurai sans
cadeau non pas noire
la fête de noël a pris rapidement
l'importance qu'on lui connaît
aujourd'hui magique émouvant c'est ce
que l'on appelle l' esprit de noël être
sur un petit nuage
à voir le sourire aux lèvres c'est le
moment de tout mettre sur pause bonheur
de joie de bonne humeur
en fait ces choses
voilà un qui font qu'on est joyeux à
cette période un général mais il
attendait on ne peut parler de noël sans
évoquer le personnage mythique qui
incarne par excellence est fait
le père noël celui qui fait le bonheur
des enfants